this is the forbes ai50 list
50 of the most promising privately held
ai companies in the us we created the ai
50 list four years ago to educate and
inform the public about ai ai stands for
artificial intelligence but the acronym
can sometimes be used to describe
augmented intelligence
augmented intelligence is when a machine
demonstrates intelligence that helps
people's intelligence out an example of
this is gps google maps doesn't drive
for you but it's smart enough to help
you navigate to where you want to go
augmenting your own driving abilities
this year's list is full of startups
augmenting human intelligence here are
five examples of augmented intelligence
on this year's list
first abnormal security abnormal
security is on a mission to keep your
email inbox safe we're all aware that
cyber attacks are on the rise but you
may not know that over ninety percent of
cyber attacks are initiated through
email abnormal security is using
advanced ai to scan email for signals of
cyber attacks and augment how we filter
out malicious email
second aurora solar aurora solar is on a
mission to bring solar to every home in
america
they use ai to build 3d solar designs on
buildings in less than 30 seconds there
ai augments the work of solar installers
so they can quote and install more solar
faster and in more locations third
cresta cresta is on a mission to improve
the customer experience they use ai for
a real-time customer agent coaching
system cresta augments the customer
service agent so that while they're on a
call they can give customers the right
answer faster in a recent survey ninety
percent of agents say that cresta has
helped them love their jobs more fourth
glean glean is on a mission to help
knowledge workers find what they're
looking for faster if you work a desk
job you probably have found yourself
looking for digital files all over the
place
glean helps you find what you're looking
for faster using a search interface kind
of like google customers report saving
two to three hours per employee per week
freeing up time to focus on higher value
work
fifth intensi
intense eye is on a mission to make
every workplace safer
using computer vision intensi can
identify unsafe workplace situations and
suggest improvements
for example if a forklift gets too close
to a group of workers at a distribution
center intensive can help inform the
safety team and help create safer
forklift pathways augmenting the health
and safety team ai companies the world
over are rapidly finding ways to augment
humans and make our lives healthier
happier safer and better
[Music]
you